say you're just opting out with videos
you just got a Swanky camera like this
Nikon z72 here thanks Nikon and you need
gear more importantly gear you can get
within your means these small rig for
ravala 360 would serve as a great
starting point to up the ante for your
journey as a content creator the
videographer journalist Tick Tock
interviewer whatever you want to be real
quick I've been using them for a few of
our videos across the mean and gaming
channels and they've been a hassle-free
experience right out of the box so let's
get the basics out of the way you get a
charging case that stores two clip-on
transmitters and the receiver and they
look very sturdy and honestly they are
quite sturdy it's a metal build on the
top with a plastic built on the sides
and an LCD screen on all transmitters
and the receiver a TRS the TRS cable to
connect the receiver to your camera a
TRS to tr RS cable for smartphones and
tablets to the cat or furry not them
windshields two metal two metal stickers
so you can place the transmitters
anywhere on your person and not weigh
down their collars like this last is
doing right now you know what happens
and lastly a Chic carrying bag to put it
all in so already I have my comms with
what's inside rather Ecom there's no
level of mic this would have been the
perfect kit for the green horn content
create the videographer but we can't
have everything can we it be like that
but for its price you're getting this
whole kit for I really can't complain
too much about the lack of a lavalier
plus they come pretty cheap or really
expensive depending on how much you care
about how your audio sounds like which
you should be caring about more at some
point when you have the cash but let's
work with what we have first so let's
move on to what we got but before we get
into that this is how it sounds like on
the road Wireless go to mics we are
using them and we've been using them
forever and they've been doing us a
solid job so let's just switch around
the road for the small rig so I've set
up the receiver on the camera behind the
and I have this thing turned on one two
three let's just put it on I'll call it
for a bit and see how it sounds like so
the transmitters and receivers have LCD
the space on them to show you the power
signal volume with the maximum muted and
if the lookup filter is engaged and
obviously Which transmitter is a or b
this is unit a and this would be Unit B
and again you don't need to stick them
out when out of the box they just come
synced so let's create the transmitters
have 3.5 millimeter Jacks for you to
plug in your lavaliers any USBC charging
port to well you know charge your units
and buttons to engage the low cut filter
and power button the receiver also has a
headphone jack for monitoring a Jack to
plug into your camera recording device a
USB C port for charging and dials for
you to adjust the gain of each
individual unit and toggle between mono
and stereo recording charging options
you can either hook up a USBC which is
provided in the Box as well directly to
charge these units up or throw them in
the case it's quite nice that they have
these options for us especially these
usba cable that's built in because you
never know if you're going to bring a
cable or whatever that would hinder you
from continuing your shoot so this is
how you adjust the gain on the receiver
and toggle between stereo and mono
here's a test with both microphones on
mono followed by them in Stereo mode I
will be having a conversation with Zaki
so you can hear how they sound like with
and without lavalier mics so this is a
test with the mono function on first
Labs on how you doing exactly I'm good
man I'm doing good just planning for the
holiday as well yeah see man
anyway yes tomorrow how do you feel
about it so far I mean it's it's a
pretty solid piece for beginners out
there right yeah okay so let's switch
gears and after that turn it to stereo
okay so now we are on the stereo
function I have the what you want you so
I bought like both channels will sound
will sound different so it won't be left
and right so if I'm not wrong oh okay
yeah there we go sorry see you would
probably be hearing me on the left and
I'll be and I'll be on the right side no
if not he'll be on the right side if not
it's probably the camera's perspective I
don't know I mean anything is fixing
post now I'm just gonna take our lives
yeah and uh see because yeah that's
that's the thing for all the times we've
been using Labs we've never actually had
tried the difference between like using
the road Labs which is like a third
party right with the small rig yeah
um and sporty has their own level years
as well
in fact you can actually use any type of
level as much as a 3.5 mm Jack because
the quality from the left and the
quality from the smaller is going to be
totally different in fact it's the same
thing with the road Wireless go so the
the quality of your left mic is also
going to be very important exactly so
just just be mindful of that yeah so
with left off we're actually going to be
using the magnets and I'll see how what
Jackie thinks about them you got a
little magnet thing over here
is this a sticker sticker or like you
can stick on something so it sticks to
your skin oh yeah
[Laughter]
oops if I do this right you see it
gravity you'll pull it down
right in the nipple there yes
okay you should have two options here
either hanging outside hanging in bro
yeah it's just it's really bad placement
man yeah it doesn't go with camera this
looks worse on camera so imagine you
have like a lean dude or lady yeah after
that
yeah just hanging out and just hanging
out like yeah it doesn't work that's
what everybody likes to do oh yeah there
we go let me find something ah
there we go
see
I mean you could always do this this is
what I call a podcast man so in a lot of
ways when we're doing some research on
this you are getting a very very similar
approach in what DJI has been doing with
the DJI mic okay with the case
same thing with the uh the way it's
styled yeah in terms of the ergonomics
it's just more or less you get less
features with a small week because of
price right exactly but the DJI mic can
also be magnetized as a clip magnet yeah
but it holds up well as well but it has
a small profile yes and the fact that uh
it comes with a like a chargeable
battery in the case itself this is just
meant to house the microphones
but you still have to like plug it in to
charge it yeah so
you are getting like a
it's gonna be hard to say this but it's
like a DJI clone sorry small rig okay
you know if you can charge the pins no
no it doesn't have a battery it doesn't
have a battery in it it's not like our
third party Road where uh where like it
has a rhythm lithium ion battery where
you can charge this and just leave it
there for what you're getting for what
you're paying you're getting a good
solid mic granted there are a lot of
Brands out there ceremonic uh what's the
other one the more accessible Brands
like what smaller is doing now look we
are powered by small red lights
stay tuned for that by the way yeah yeah
and the small we have been doing camera
cages monitors teleprompters almost
everything so you can kind of see that
they have a shift in pocket I mean like
if you need something that works with
the hotkeys that protects all the
equipment without increasing extra cost
yeah it's only one package to be honest
it's good yeah all right so I think
we've pretty much got this covered a
small rig w60 wireless microphones
affordable
portable
it's called great range pretty decent
performance too and how small this is
going to save you so much space so much
space and speaking of space Here's a
message from our sponsor Jesus
this video is brought to you by Asus
check out the Asus Zenbook 14x OLED
Space Edition commemorating the 25th
anniversary of the first Asus laptop
sent into space Not only does it offer a
space exclusive design but it's even
worthy of going where no man has gone
before with its space gray durability it
even comes with a 3.5 inch OLED
companion Zen Vision display and you
will have a ball of time taking
interviews with a 16x10 4K OLED Nano
Edge Pantone validated 14 inch display
now a test with the transmitters with
the low cut filter turned on with our
fan over there indirectly at me okay so
before we start the test let's engage
the low cut filter by pressing the
button right here below the power button
so this is how the small rate for revala
w60 sounds like with the low cut filter
turned on and a fan directly on me so
this is how it sounds like without a
lavalier and the local filter turned off
with a fan blasting towards my Direction
so now let's put on the level here again
our level layers are Road level layers
one thing to note the jack for the
lavalier is on the side of the
transmitter so just be mindful when
putting the transmitter in your pocket
because you don't want to screw up your
lavalier so this is how it sounds like
with the lavalier and the low cut filter
turned on with a fan blasting directly
towards me
so this is how it sounds like with the
low cut filter turned off with a leveler
mic
so this is how this how the effect for a
value will sound like in a real world
setting with a lot of traffic going
around so if you guys are doing blocks
or you know interviews on the streets
this is basically how it will sound like
but we need to attach the windshield
real quick and just find a spot but
yeah this is without the local filter
all right and this is how the small rig
for revala w60 sounds like with the low
cut photo on in a real world setting
with traffic going on my right
construction on my left and yeah I I'm
pretty sure it sounds good so this is
how you attach the windshield it just
kind of screws on like the roads do
plug him in and he's turned and like
that it is secured
okay so now we're walking back to the
office the windshield is on and this is
how it sounds like without the locator
on in a real world environment with
traffic going on now on my left and
construction on my right
it should sound good
so let's try it out with the local
filter all right so this is how the
small ring for Revival w60 sounds like
with the Loca filter on and the wind
chill on as well clipped on to my shirt
and yeah that's traffic on my left it's
a van coming and there's construction
right behind me so this is how it will
sound like in a real world test
so I'll be reviewing the footage there
is a distinct difference between having
it on and off though you could always
use a low pass filter in post so let's
stop range the small rig forever like
w60 has a range of 100 meters
unobstructed but right now Zaki is there
in our office three stories up shooting
it and he's experiencing a bit of
stuttering but that's also because you
know there's a lot of unseen obstacles
in a way like radio waves Wi-Fi signals
and all and obviously we lost our
connections when we were in the lift and
through thicker concrete walls but let's
be honest here you guys won't be
shooting like this all the time right if
this was made for the Casual content
creator so the receiver will always be
near you whether you're shooting travel
Vlogs or you know the pool Vlogs or
anything if you're shooting in the
studio these will be perfect because
again let's be honest you won't be
shooting like this right now
really so after reviewing all the tasks
we've done I can say that the small
recovery w60 can hold its own and record
great sounding audio with a low-cut
filter working to a degree the
windshields work fine and the options
for model and stereo together with all
the bits of equipment you get in the kit
it's quite the bargain but how does it
stack up against another product like
the road Wireless go through Max that we
use as our daily drivers so there is a
slight difference between the both of
them with the road having a slightly
better sound quality but it's so
marginal to most ears people won't be
able to tell the difference of course
Road has the road Central app which has
a lot of set things available for the
mics but Simplicity is key for the green
horn and if I were on a budget I'd go
with a small rig because of the charging
case that comes with it but of course
there are areas that the roads shine in
but we can't deny that small work has
the whole package right from the gecko
which begs the question would you get
one for yourself if you have any
questions about the small rig for
Revival w60 leave them in the comment
section down below and I'll do my best
to get to them but in the meantime make
sure to follow us on all of our socials
right here and maybe leave a like And
subscribe to us it goes a long way and
if you like this video check this out
[Music]